大家好,我是期货求魔。
今天跟大家分享的是第五节,人性管理。
基本上这节课就是我们本系列课程的最后一节课。
那么关于人性管理这个话题,基本上是老生常谈。
可能大家都在网上或者各种视频上都能够听到
或者看到关于这个期货里面的人性管理的一个各种各样的一个说法吧。
很多人包括各种高手都会认为这个期货
成功的一个关键就在于我们这个客服人性的弱点。
但是这个人性真的不是那么容易能做到客服的。
在我的理解里面,其实我把我们期货交易分为两个阶段。
那么在这个两个阶段里面,分别会遇到两个大的困难。
第一个困难就是第一阶段,就是建立这个交易系统。
那么交易系统的一个困难,困难在于一般如果你没有特别的方向,
你不知道怎么入手去建立你这个交易系统。
所以困难就是在于你缺乏对这个交易系统构建的一个认知。
只有当你在这个实践的过程中记得到一定的程度,
那么你慢慢的慢慢的才会对自己交易系统一个构建的方向有了这个确定。
那等你这个方向一定要确定了有了方向,那么其实交易系统的建立还是比较容易的。
当到了第二阶段这个人性管理,这个就不是一般人能够成功。
往往这个人性管理是阻碍了很多人在期货上或者交易,或者成功的一个半角石。
所以这些人性管理这一块呢其实我也没有太多的太多太多跟大家做这个分享,
也特别有效的人性管理的措施。
我也只是就自己所自己的经历的体验跟大家做一个分享。
那么气候,那么在这个人性管理这一块的话,
我个人觉得就是人性管理的一个中心在这个提到这个我们交易人的一个风险意思,
还有对这个自己交易系统的一个直升力上。
那么在一个交易系统你建立之后呢,
如果你不能够有效的执行,
那么你这个交易系统其实就没有了太大的意义,
你也很难获得这个交易上的成功。
那如何提高这个风险意思?
其实我挺羡慕的,
因为有些人天生就对就有比较好的一个风险意思,
他不用刻意去培养,
所以他可以省下很多的时间还有精神成本。
但像我们,像我还有很多人,
大部分都是风险意识的不会特别强,
很多时候是要靠吃亏还有后天的培养和强化,
才能够建立一个比较强的一个风险意思。
在这方面的话,女人就性别,
女人可能相比男人来讲,
可能在风险意思上会更高一点点。
那么这里的话我简单谈三点关于一个风险意思提高的一些措施吧。
第一点实践,
因为其实很多风险意思是只有你伤害过,
你是被伤害过之后,你才会意识到这个风险。
所以只有实践,在实践中中国不停的亏钱,
还有大的亏钱,
那么你说到伤害之后,
那么你才能够慢慢的形成对这个风险意思的,
潜意识的一种这种认知。
第二点就是学习,
我经常会看一些期货上一些失败的案例,
因为看这些案例能够大概了解它失败的原因,
很多都是在这个风险意思,
风险管理上的一些问题上。
所以看这些对于你之后遇到的一个可能大概的一些情况,
你可能都有一心理上,
都会有一种意识去归归这种可能发生的一些风险。
那么第三点,交流,
那么这个我印象最深刻,
而且我觉得最近自己年代的话,
也是所欲飞浅的一点,
就是多跟我们这期货上的一些职业的专业的人士多交流,
因为这些人的一个风险意识,
他们能做到这个职业,
其实他们的一风风意识远比很多人,
尤其是像我们这种粤语的人,
那么意识肯定会强很多。
所以跟他们交流之后,
在无形中你慢慢会形成对意识的一个概念,
那么这个对于你在交易的时候都是会有啟发的。
以前我一开始接触这个期货,
也进入这个期货的时候,
听好多的书记还有很多人说,
我们应该坚持自己,
应该不要太多的跟人家做交流,
因为会受别人的影响。
所以有很长一段时间,
我也是偏向自己做交易,
不跟人交流,
但后面我发现真的是错了。
为什么错了呢?
因为作为一个刚入这个期货,
交易的人来讲,
我们本身对于这个期货的认知,
还对于期货的一些经验,
以及这个基础都很弱。
那么这时候你自己去闭门照吃,
你缺乏基础,
所以你根本是照不出什么吃的,
更不是什么吃的,
反而这样会限制你的一个事业,
很多的一些方法,
一些经验,
都是通过跟别人,
尤其是跟一些专业的高手交流之后,
你可能会得到更多的啟发。
所以我觉得好,
那些所谓我只个人做答,
不与人交流的这种方式,
真的是不可取。
第二点,关于提高自信力的问题,
那么这个自信力的问题,
主要是对于你交易系统的自信力,
那么这里自信力的话,
我们其实也没有太多的好一些建议,
或者举出,我个人的一些做法,
我把它总结成主动和被动的,
也是我目前,
这几年一直在采取的一些方法和方式,
那么被动这一块的话,
我这里提到的四点,
第一跟第二点,
都是通过这种有点逃避的心理,
第一种就利用这种交易软件的一些云条件单的功能,
来强制的去执行我的一些,
一些平常的一些动作,
因为有时候我们在行情积极变化,
那么可能我们会有一些心理上的一些不死,
不死的平常,
那可能会给大家造成一些不必要的风险,
承受不必要的死,
为他人下单,由他人带为下单,
这个方式其实在前几年的时候我也讲过,
然后给一点的一些提成,
给这个下单员,
后面我放弃了,
因为什么呢?
因为本身我的一个资产就是职业,
交易人,
所以就是说,你由他人带为下单,
这个其实很不利于培养自己的一个交易心理,
对于你这个交易水平其实是很大影响的。
那如果是说你们是团队的,
那这个另外说,
如果不是团队的为培养自己个人的一个能力的,
那么自己点的话其实不建议,
当然如果团队作传的方式的话,
我觉得还是用这种可能会更加好一点点,
因为可以避免,
因为个人的一些问题,
导致的一些没必要的一些损失,
资金管理和仓位管理,
其实是多数交易人会提到最多的两个措施吧。
那么所谓资金管理呢,
就是说你能用的资金,
分多少来做这个期货交易,
然后在你这个交易里面,
多少用来进仓,
总而言之,
就是说你有这么多资金,
当时你不能把这个所有的资金都投在一次,
或者两次的这种机会里面。
仓位管理呢,
仓位管理就是我们经常说的,
我的仓位不能超过三成,
或者是说我当个品种不能超过多少成,
这种方式来降低风险。
那么这两个资金管理,
一个仓位管理呢,
其实说的好听点呢,
就叫做风险管理,
说的不好听点呢,
就是给自己,
降低心理负担,
找一个比较好的一个借口。
为什么有些人他资金管理,
他根本就是资金管理,
或者仓位管理呢,
人家其实不是特别在乎,
满餐进满餐出,
这个也没什么太大的问题吧,
尤其像我们仓位管理是吧,
那种草丹,
那基本上都满餐进满餐出,
所以说不同的一个风格呢,
他不一定说我们一定是要这个仓位管理,
所以呢,
其实资金管理和仓位管理呢,
其实如果是说按照这么来讲的话,
其实更多的就是一种被动的,
我是为了让自己的心理好受一点点,
不要承担太大的question,
所以说做出了一种被动的几错,
所以我把它归难为成一个被动的一个措施。
那么主动的一个措施呢,
其实我觉得这个是大家最应该去琢磨,
并且把它固定下来的,
第一种的,
第一个呢就是这个副盘和交易计划,
那么基本上多数的一个比较成熟,
或者比较成功的一些交易人呢,
像这是一个固定的动作,
副盘也交易计划,
那么它的一个好处呢,
就是说什么呢,
我副盘,
选择好业品种,
发现是和我们这个交易系统的,
可能在明天,
然后呢,
接下来的行情里面可能会出现的一个机会,
我们提前把它给锁定了,
那么在机会出现之后呢,
我们就能够做到心中有底,
不乱动,
也不会受情绪影响太大,
也有时候呢,
我们在计划以外,
或者是说随便盘中乱动,
经常会吃亏,
有时候吃亏的时候呢,
就会变得情绪很激动,
或者心血来潮,
那么这样就更容易出错,
那么成熟的损失就越来越大,
所以副盘和交易计划很有必要,
那么关于这个副盘和交易计划怎么做,
其实不同的人有不同的方式,
如果有机会的话,
可以跟大家就职方面交流,
第二点的话,
是我个人比较强烈建议的总结,
成功概率大的一些开堂机会,
有时候我们,
在某段时间里面,
可能作弹会经常错,
或者是说会经常亏损,
这个时候呢,
我们就会变得胆怯,
有时候呢,
我们看准了,
但是我们不敢下单,
如果你能够发现这么一些机会,
然后大胆做进去了,
也成功了,
通过一辆车的成功呢,
让你的信心恢复,
这个很关键,
那么自怎么恢复呢,
就是这一个工作,
能够让你达到这个目的。
第三,
跟这个提高风险意思一样,
也要多做交流,
多做交流,
因为怎么说呢,
别人的一些想法,
或者别人的一些建议呢,
其实也是对自己的一个起发,
也是对自己有意识的去控制,
还有提高自己自信力的一个,
一个很好的一些警醒的措施。
第四呢,
呃,
参加模拟考好了,
现在这个,
呃,
市场上呢,
就有很多这种,
呃,
拭目啊,
或者一些什么配置公司啊,
打折以招聘这个,
交易员的民意,
啊,
来做的这些模拟考好了,
呃,
那其实这个模拟考好了呢,
其实我们的目的呢,
我觉得好可以去,
去去去参与一下,
呃,
目的呢不是说,
为了真的是要,
实现他那个交易,
那个,
呃,
成为他们的交易员,
当然你能够达达他要求的话,
啊,
去做这个交易员也没问题,
但是我的目的就是什么呢?
我们的目的是什么呢?
我们的目的就是说,
呃,
他比单纯的这种,
模拟考和,
呃,
接近四盘,
因为他有条件的一些约束,
那么通过这种,
模拟考和,
有条件的模拟考和,
啊,
去磨练你对系统的一些,
呃,
交易系统的一个自信力,
啊,
不断的修正,
完善,
修正完善,
啊,
提高自己一个自信力,
那么其实,
这也是一个很好的作诗,
呃,
那么这种方式呢,
你,
呃,
一般情况是这种跑合,
一般是不限吃素的,
所以呢,
吃的去,
去,
去试,
啊,
这其实是挺好的一种,
可以利用起来,
然后,
最后呢,
就最重要的,
最重要呢,
就是,
还是回归,
实践,
呃,
如果你没经历过,
这个诗盘,
那么你谈之前的,
所谓的,
啊,
分空一时啊,
或者提高自信力啊,
啊,
这些你都没有一些,
切身的,
啊,
很深刻的一些,
体会跟理解,
所以呢,
还是具,
还是真理,
实践,
才是真理,
那么实践的过程之后呢,
你要去总结,
那么总结,
你之后呢,
你再把你总结出来结果,
再用于实践,
再用于,
啊,
总结,
总结之后再用于实践,
那么这样子,
你才能够提高,
要不然的话,
有些人做三年呢,
他能够,
啊,
就能够实现这个盈利了,
你有些人做了十几二十年,
还是一直属于亏损的状态,
我觉得这个,
十几,
十几二十年呢,
赔了大把的一个青春,
还有大把的金钱,
最终收获的是,
很可悲的结果,
这些是挺,
挺,
挺悲剧的,
我相信大部分人,
不想走到这一步,
那么基本上这些课的话,
就跟大家简单交流到这里,
啊,